el actual agujero de ozono la Barrera
protectora del planeta que filtra los
rayos ultravioletas del sol está en vías
de recuperarse en 40 años según
científicos de Naciones Unidas
la eliminación progresiva del casi 99%
de las sustancias prohibidas que agotan
la capa de ozono ha preservado el ozono
y ha contribuido significativamente a la
recuperación de la estratosfera Superior
y a la reducción de la exposición humana
a la dañina radiación ultravioleta del
Sol
el protocolo de Montreal firmado en 1987
por 195 países ha permitido reducir las
emisiones de gases responsables del
agujero de la capa de ozono desde el
principio de los años 80 gases emitidos
principalmente en el pasado por
numerosos frigoríficos como resultado si
se mantienen las políticas actuales en
2066 el agujero sobre la antártida
debería haber desaparecido
realmente demuestra que el medio
ambiente es frágil que las actividades
humanas pueden modificar el medio
ambiente y una vez perturbado el medio
ambiente se tarda mucho tiempo en volver
a la normalidad
los expertos advierten que hay que
permanecer vigilantes en los próximos
años porque la composición completa de
la capa de ozono depende también de la
limitación de nuestras emisiones de
gases de efecto invernadero en cuanto a
las técnicas de geoingeniería a veces
previstas para combatir el calentamiento
global podrían hacer más mal que bien